فقالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه شنت اكثر من 50 هجوما من منظومه
الصواريخ خلال ليله الماضيه كما نفذت اربع
غارات جويه وخمسه عشره ضربه صاروخيه
معظمها على البنيه التحتيه المدنيه لمناطق
خلال
وافادت هيئه الاركان بان قوتها مستمره في
صد الهجمات الروسيه باتجاهات بخموت ومناطق
اخرى من دونيتسكو
وذكرت انها اسقطت صاروخاي كروز من نوع
كاليبر ونفذت سته ضربات على مناطق تمركز
القوات الروسيه
ومعداتها العسكريه وعلى موقع نظام الدفاع
الجوي
واضافت ان الروسي يواجهون مشاكل في الدعم
اللوجيسي لوحدتهم نظرا لما سمته فشل انظمه
الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات وفق قولها
معنى الان ملكيه مراسله الجزيره كاترينا
حنا كاترين صباح الخير نرصد معك جديد
السياسي والميداني بالاضافه الى بيان هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه
صباح الخير ازدهار نعم بالفعل القصف
الروسي الصاروخي لا يتوقف بشكل يومي على
اوكرانيا
والهجمات الروسيه ايضا لا تتوقف لا سيما
على محاور القتال في الشرق تحديدا في
دنياتك وعلى وجه الخصوص باتجاهات بخموت
ولمن وايضا في خركاف بحسب ما افاد بيان
وهيئه الاركان هذا الصباح الهجمات
الصاروخيه كذلك لا تتوقف اكثر من 15
صاروخا تم ضربها على مناطق البنى التحتيه
في
ايضا وسط البلاد وكذلك على خرسون جنوبا
الرئيس زيلينسكي في خطابه المسائي وصف
المعارك في دنيتك تحديدا بانها الاكثر
وحشيه طبعا سبق له في الايام الماضيه ان
وصفها بانها الاكثر صعوبه والاكثر سخونه
بالامس وصفها بانها الاكثر وحشيه وانه
يعتمد على ما يجري هناك
تحضير لما تتحضر له اوكرانيا في المستقبل
القريب بالامس اوكرانيا وسلطاتها ازدهار
كانت تتحدث بشكل ايجابي جدا عما كان يدور
في اليومين الماضيين في مؤتمر ميونخ للامن
اعتبرت انها تلقت جرعه دعم قويه من
حلفائها في ذلك المؤتمر الرئيس الاوكراني
قال ان انتصار اوكرانيا حسب تعبيره كان
مسيطرا على خطابات قاده العالم وتوقع
مزيدا من الدعم ليس فقط على صعيد الاسلحه
الدفاعيه بل كذلك على صعيد الصواريخ بعيده
المدى وما قال انه الدعم العسكري الطويل
الامد ايضا
لاوكرانيا كان وزير خارجيه اوكرانيا
مشاركا في ميونخ وكانت له الكثير من
التصريحات من هناك التي تحدثت عن ضروره ان
يتم تسليح اوكرانيا بشكل متزايد وخاصه
بشكل سريع تحدث عن موضوع المقاتلات
الحربيه حيث دعا خلفاء اوكرانيا الى عدم
تكرار ما جرى في مساله الدبابات بحيث ان
الدبابات تم اتخاذ القرار
بتوريدها لاوكرانيا بشكل متاخر واليوم
تجري التدريبات فقال انه يجب ان يحصل
العكس في مساله المقاتلات الحربيه فتجري
التدريبات من قبل الحلفاء ومن ثم يتخذ
القرار بتوريدها الى اوكرانيا وبدا
متفائلا في هذا الموضوع اشير ايضا الى
مساله تعليق وزير خارجيه اوكرانيا بالامس
على مبادره الصين للسلام في اوكرانيا حيث
قال ان هناك ثوابت لاوكرانيا ترتكز بشكل
اساسي على عدم التنازل عن اي قطعه ارض
بحسب ما تقول اوكرانيا تحتلها روسيا وان
اي رؤيه للسلام في المستقبل يجب ان تنطلق
مما سماه النضال من اجل الحريه اشير كذلك
ازدهار الى نقطه مهمه كان قد تحدث عنها
الرئيس الاوكراني في خطابه المسائي لها
علاقه بمس الطاقه والكهرباء بالامس اعلن
الرئيس زلينسكي ان معظم اراضي اوكرانيا
لديها طاقه ومعظم الشعب الاوكراني اليوم
لديه كهرباء تحدث تحديدا عن اوديسا وذلك
بحسب مقال لان التعافي يستمر واصلاح منشات
الطاقه التي تضررت وتدمرت في معظم اراضي
اوكرانيا بسبب القصف الروسي هذا التعافي
يستمر كذلك شاكرا كل الحلفاء الذين دعموا
الطاقه وهذا القطاع في اوكرانيا علما انه
في الاسابيع الماضيه تلقت اوكرانيا الكثير
من الدعم بدءا من القمه الاوروبيه
الاوكرانيه مرورا بكل المسؤولين الدوليين
الذين زاروكيا في الايام والاسابيع
الماضيه كلهم
ركزوا على موضوع الطاقه بحيث ان اكثر من
50% من منشات الطاقه في اوكرانيا بحسب ما
اعلنت السلطات هنا كانت قد تضررت بشكل
كامل او جزئي بسبب القصف الروسي لاسيما في
الاشهر الماضيه ازدهار مراسله الجزيره
كاترين حنا شكرا جزيلا لك